quoi g j'ai déjà fait une vidéo sur les
jeux vidéo non mais c'est normal c'est
normal c'est parce que en fait là c'est
la suite
1 j'ai juste fait une pause entre temps
une pause de presque un an
oui oui ça commence à faire une bonne
pause la session alors je suis désolé
mais il ya trop d'incohérences dans les
jeux vidéo un même
même dans mes jeux vidéo préférés quoi
par exemple j'adore zelda
voilà ça mais je préférais j'adore jouer
pendant 40 heures pour sauver la
princesse et avoir un bisou sur la joue
en échange c'est super mais dans ce jeu
je vois que ça ne choque personne
absolument personne le système dépôt
placé dans les maisons
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce jeu un autre jeu que
j'adore le jeu vidéo auquel j'ai le plus
joué quand j'étais gamin c'est pokémon
sur game boy voilà c'est dit pikachu
draco fera t-box mais qui qui a eu
l'idée de mettre une seule sauvegarde
dans le jeu une seule une alors
forcément il t'arrive ça en fait ces
primates en écoutant pokémon j'ai
presque terminé le jeu en fait c'est pas
ma gameboy sa saisie et tu as raison il
est trop bien ton je tape à sauvegarder
j'espère abassi je te rapelle roucoule
niveau 4 temmar un peu au jeu nippon
bonjour de chance aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je le reconnais il ya des éditeurs qui
font des efforts ça mais c'était
franchement pas la peine je de vie par
exemple
bon bah dans pas mal de jeux maintenant
il y en a plus comme d'ordre call of
duty ou gears of war un
maintenant tu te prends une balle ça va
pas bien et puis tu attends un peu et ça
va mieux
comme dans la vraie vie quoi on est cool
je vais mourir au nom à ça va mieux
tu pourras monopoly je fais la banque
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup mieux
alors dans les nouveaux jeux un autre
truc qui est pas mal en skyrim 1 150
heures de jeu des graphismes
éblouissants et c'est quand un ennemi
s'approche la musique change paye ton
suspense c'est pas la peine de
m'attaquer je sais que tu es là qu'est
ce que j'ai dit ah bon c'est pas ça le
vrai problème dans les jeux vidéo parce
que moi le truc qui m'énerve le plus sur
terre encore plus que dragonball
evolution on voit ça qui fait des
travaux au cortex les chapeaux de chéri
bref le truc qui me donne envie de tout
casser
c'est quand je suis entre deux mecs qui
discutent d'un jeu que je connais pas à
28,9 j'ai fait quoi dans l'herbe et le
spot de la map citant perso suis encore
sur mw2 est mon seul clip c'est une
triple aux spots highrise la première
chose que les semis par exemple quand la
sphère dans ce jeu se joue le machine de
guerre plus lg pour tenter d'établir
schots le dernier mythe vivant quoi le
pire c'est les mecs qui font du 70 pour
le reste m quoi allo n'importe quoi
alors généralement leur temps mon ump 45
et leur met des bons gros d'europe 1
on les refait en plein middle il adore
ça quand c'est comme ça j'ai juste envie
de faire une seule chose là je suis un
f4 toute la prem
alors ici donc c'est quand la dernière
fois que j'avais une copine 1
non dans les signes ça compte pas au
fait tu peux rejoindre ma page facebook
et voir toutes mes autres vidéos sur
cyprien point fr à bientôt
[Musique]